you know what's really uh
fun
is I love watching people 100 commit and
this is something you do really well and
the other cast members but you commit
when you commit it's something I believe
in religiously which is you have to go
in 110 percent so when you lose your
when you lose your as Charlie Kelly
it's or in any role you're doing you go
full full out and and I think that
that's a quality of the show there's no
restraint when it's time to go it is
complete meltdowns complete insane
meltdowns yeah I don't want to feel as
though I've left anything on the table
you have not
and honestly this is going to sound like
actor BS but I go into a like trance
like I dilute myself and I'm gone and
I'll come out of a scene and be like I
have no idea what I did I hope it was
good yeah and then I'll get in the
editing room like no it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't but that one was that one was
was good so sometimes I can't do that
and I'm hyper aware of the camera guys
here or the the boom guy's got a cold
he's like you know you're aware but
sometimes you just blackout and then and
just I don't know just kind of barf out
a performance and and it seems like
vomit on the screen and uh and uh the
audience loves it because they say
that's real
um there's a really weird thing I uh I
don't know you could probably relate to
this but there are a lot of things I
can't do if it needs to be serious or
sincere oh yeah but if it's
um in the in the name of Comedy I feel
that I might be able there are times
where I've felt I might be able to break
the world record for a mile if I thought
it would make an audience full of people
laugh yeah yeah you know what I mean of
course there are things you can do and
obviously that is not the case but there
are times where
um I I know we would do something at
rehearsal and I would say like okay when
there's an audience here I I think I can
put my fist through that because if I do
it will be funny and so I will and it
doesn't matter and then later on I'll
realize that I shattered my hands
but I don't know what that is that is
yeah there's a kind of um
you know for lack of a better word it's
neediness it's like I so want to make I
so want people to be happy and laughing
that uh in that moment
I used to do stuff all the time on The
Late Night show and Andy would like get
mad at me afterwards he would go like
did you realize you you know that was a
real bear and you put your you put your
like you head you know in his mouth and
I said yeah just at the moment like I
thought that'd be kind of funny because
it's so wrong I think it's adrenaline I
think
something in you wants to be a performer
wants to reach the audience and then
as soon as you sign up to do that you
commit to do it especially on a talk
show or suddenly there is a group of
people standing in front of you dive in
and you say okay now we're flying flying
without a net that's not the expression
but uh flying by the seat of our pants
we're going by the seat of our pants and
uh and there's no backing down and I
guess suddenly you find yeah I have my
head in a bear's mouth what am I doing
but it's just the adrenaline of it just
carries you and I would look at it later
on yeah we did a uh a tour and it's 2010
and you were probably there for this
Sona but yeah we were in some venue and
it was going really well and I was in
the crowd and then I got up on the ledge
Yes and there's like a 30-foot drop into
the audience yeah I remember and I'm
like on the ledge and like doing stick
to make the crowd laugh
and Andy rightly was Furious you're like
the Tom Cruise of Comedy you're gonna
die that way hey whether you're stuck in
traffic or streaming your favorite
podcasts that's where I come in it's
important to have a network you can
trust wherever you are say it with me
T-Mobile
yeah you didn't really have to say it
with me but it is your network you know
I'm excited about T-Mobile yeah you're
killing it and uh you know I was really
excited is our good friend blay who's
been using this service blade tell us
about it yeah I have been a T-Mobile a
subscriber for a really long time it
they're awesome I download videos all
the time yeah you do you like you
download a lot of videos yeah now you've
never read a book
books are overrated but uh and I listen
to this podcast on a hike fantastic up
in the mountains you listen to our
podcast I will contract you work here
yeah I have to I have to I have to
listen to it but it's great and and
honestly like the coverage is is insane
uh and yeah I love the service I love
the phone it's fantastic experience for
yourself how T-Mobile is America's
largest and fastest 5G Network you can't
top them I like all the G's you bet you
do find out more at t-mobile.com Cy
that's
s-e-e-w-h-y fastest based on median
overall combined 5G speeds according to
analysis by UCLA of speed test
intelligence data 4.
Q4 2022 good wow that's incredible yeah
I said exactly what they wanted
5G details at
t-mobile.com what I'm saying is I I
acknowledge I'm you know I don't want it
to be a uh a humble brag or a flex
because I'm often afterwards realizing
oh this is the sign of something that
needs work
honestly like this is the this is I'm a
smart person and I have a wife and kids
and I love my family and relatives and I
know better than to do that why did I do
that it's because I knew that the crowd
is this happy uh you know Hand high up
but if I can I could Notch it up a
little higher if I stood up on the ledge
wouldn't that be cool well it could be
you're opening yourself up to not to get
too sort of hoity-toity with it maybe
something is acting through you some
universe or higher power or whatever you
want to call it where you are just
opening yourself up to as as much
creativity as you can muster right which
is to say I'm Conan O'Brien I want to
make people laugh and then once you
commit to that you don't really know
where you're going to come out on the
other end you don't really know whether
you're going to do something crazy with
the audience or stick your head in the
in the Bear's mouth because you're just
open to whatever
if you're Tom Cruise
and you entertain people by doing
death-defying stunts then potentially
it's the same kind of thing where you
just that's how you communicate with
people and you are doing it over and
over again I think for you and I it's
easier with comedy because that was
probably a safe place for you as a kid
growing up oh yeah you know if you I
couldn't do anything Tom Cruise does
include run convincingly
you know like that's the other thing too
is I'd like to see it though no you know
what I you know what I would love to do
I would love to do uh this just reminds
me of something I've really been itching
to do and I'm just gonna say it right
now but
um we've been shooting something uh for
HBO Max where I travel around and hook
uh meet up with fans kind of a travel
show idea and we were going to be we
shot one in Norway already and we knew
that there's a possibility that Tom
Cruise would be in like the same area
that we were in and I've I've worked
with him before and he was really great
he's very funny uh played it perfectly
he was a joy to work with
but the idea is I want to shoot a
segment where he teaches me how to run
the way he runs in a movie because
apparently there's a whole technique to
it because it's very back straight arms
are pointy yes and if you Terminator if
you don't do it exactly right you look
like a fool and what I've always thought
is I'd really like really good cameras
like him to run and then I would like to
run the way I run and not trying to be
funny just run the way a six foot four
not very athletic man my age runs and
run but with the real cameras and stuff
and then put the music to it and I think
it would be one of the funniest things
about it go get that bear and just set
the bear loose and and you will run
convincing yeah yeah it's funny the bear
everyone was like the you know was what
if the bear had uh had you know bitten
me or something when I I forgot it was
my hand or my head or whatever but I
shoved something in the Bear's mouth and
I think the Bear Just recoiled at my
neediness
and I saw the bear backstage talking to
other bears like it just comes from a
bad place the needy ones do not taste
makes the muscles all sinewy
really needy and makes the meat taste
better yeah yeah oh no it makes it worse
yeah
I don't know why the Bears are smoking
in my but the needy worst they are just
uh of course they are like a sour grape